La energía nuclear es como el entretenimiento
para adultos.
Poca gente reconoce que le gusta pero luego
te lo encuentras en todas partes.
Y da lo mismo que la empresa que os suministra
electricidad diga que la suya es 100% renovable.
En la red eléctrica, todos los kilovatios
son iguales.
Así que, amigos de Visual Politik, por si
no erais conscientes os lo digo: ahora mismo
es muy posible que estéis consumiendo energía
nuclear.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando, Fonseca
macho, eres un provocador.
No hay centrales nucleares en todo el mundo.
De hecho, solo hay 30 países con centrales
nucleares.
Es decir, que solo uno de cada 6-7 países
en el mundo tiene reactores.
Pero esperad un momento porque, hablando claro,
no tiene las mismas necesidades energéticas
Vanuatu que China.
Si hablamos de las principales economías
del mundo, las agrupadas en el G-20, solo
hay 5 países sin nucleares.
Y de estos Turquía ya está construyendo
una central e Italia importa un 10% de su
electricidad de las nucleares de Francia.
Por lo tanto, es un hecho: las principales
economías del mundo utilizan la energía
nuclear.
Y las economías emergentes lo tienen muy
claro.
En otros vídeos ya os hemos hablado del crecimiento
económico de China.
Pues bien, hay tres indicadores que van de
la mano desde hace décadas: crecimiento económico,
más demanda energética y mayor contaminación.
Así que imaginaos por un momento las industrias
chinas necesitando cada vez más energía.
A eso le podemos sumar la migración de la
población rural a las ciudades… Pensadlo
bien… de repente tenemos miles de oficinas,
fábricas, centros de ocio, servicios y millones
de chinos encendiendo la luz a la vez.
Beijing, Shanghai o Shenzen son megalópolis
que hacen que Madrid, Caracas o Washington
parezcan un pueblecito de los Alpes.
Así que ya os podéis hacer una idea de toda
la energía que necesitan.
Esto explica que China se esté convirtiendo
en la Disneylandia de las energías renovables.
No hacen más que instalar placas solares,
parques eólicos y centrales hidroeléctricas.
Año tras año China lidera la inversión
en renovables.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando, después
del incidente de FUKUSHIMA, en Japón, no
tienen muchas ganas de construir reactores
nucleares ¿Verdad?
Pues… os equivocáis.
Según datos del Organismo Internacional de
la Energía Atómica, en Asia se construyen
hoy día más de la mitad de los reactores
nucleares que se están desarrollando en el
mundo.
Y no son 3 o 4.
Son 27 en total, repartidos principalmente
entre China, India y Corea del Sur.
En otras palabras, a pesar de Fukushima, la
apuesta energética de Asia no se está limitando
a las renovables sino también a la nuclear.
Y diréis ¡Claro!
¡Todo esto es porque China es una dictadura
que no necesita escuchar a su pueblo!
¿Verdad?
Pues nada más lejos de la realidad.
Por ejemplo, el Gobierno de Taiwán, que es
democrático, sacó un referendum para cerrar
sus centrales nucleares ¿Y qué dijeron los
taiwaneses?
Pues un rotundo NO.
Incluso desde Japón nos llegan noticias como
esta.
Un tribunal de Japón rechaza una demanda
contra la construcción de una central nuclear
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Por qué los países
de Asia insisten en instalar centrales nucleares
cuando hay otras alternativas?
Y también estaréis pensando ¿cuáles son
las compañías que siguen apostando por la
nuclear y qué tecnología utilizan?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
EL DRAGÓN DORMIDO
¿Os acordáis del dragón Smaug en El Hobbit,
dormido sobre montañas de oro?
Bueno, pues en la China de hace 50 años,
Mao Tse Tung era ese dragón dormido pero
en lugar de oro y riquezas lo que había era
granos de arroz.
El país era profundamente agrícola y permaneció
durante décadas en el subdesarrollo.
Por eso no debe extrañar que China llegara
más de 30 años tarde a eso de la energía
nuclear.
Hasta principios de los años 90 China no
tenía ninguna central.
En 1990, sin ir más lejos, el mix eléctrico
de China consistía en un 20% de hidroeléctricas
y un 80% de gas, petróleo y sobretodo, carbón.
En 2017, los combustibles fósiles aún mantienen
un peso del 71% en su mix de generación eléctrica.
Y ya sabéis lo que esto significa: carbón
a tope, chinos con mascarillas y neblina en
las ciudades que impiden prácticamente ver
el sol.
Y no parece que la cosa vaya a cambiar viendo
noticias como ésta del pasado septiembre:
El boom de la construcción de plantas de
carbón en China provoca una alarma climática
Pensadlo bien, el único recurso natural que
tiene China es el carbón.
Así que no están dispuestos a renunciar
a ello.
Mientras tanto, la hidroeléctrica se mantiene
con un 19% y las renovables suponen un 6%.
El 4% restante, quedaos con este porcentaje,
el 4%, lo aportan los 40 reactores nucleares
que China ha construido en estos 27 años,
que son más de los que operan en Rusia actualmente.
¿Qué ha pasado para encontrarnos con estos
datos?
Pues un dato que es francamente brutal.
La demanda eléctrica de China se ha multiplicado
por 10 desde 1990.
En otras palabras, con todas las centrales
nucleares que se han construido en China se
suministraría la mitad de la energía que
el país necesitaba en 1990.
Hoy tan solo es el 4%.
El dragón dormido ha despertado y de qué
manera.
SED DE URANIO
Al dragón Smaug le encantaba el oro.
Al dragón chino le encanta el uranio.
Ahora mismo China está construyendo 11 reactores
más con una capacidad superior a toda la
potencia nuclear que tiene actualmente el
Reino Unido.
Pero esperad un momento, porque tenéis que
ver cuál es la previsión para 2030:
La Agencia Internacional de la Energía dice
que China superará a Estados Unidos como
la mayor nación de energía nuclear
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
Todas estas previsiones son después del tsunami
de 2011 en Japón.
Ese tsunami que provocó el accidente en la
central nuclear de Fukushima.
Todo un área devastada, cientos de miles
de desplazados, aguas contaminadas.
Una catástrofe.
Así que ¿por qué seguir invirtiendo en
energía nuclear?
Básicamente, se puede decir que hay un elemento
clave en la producción energética que es
que la electricidad no puede almacenarse.
Quizás en unos años las baterías de litio
den un salto tecnológico y eliminen este
inconveniente pero a día de hoy es caro e
inviable almacenar electricidad a gran escala.
Y este es el principal problema de las renovables.
Las placas solares están muy bien pero…
¿Cómo producimos energía por la noche?
Además, la base del sistema eléctrico de
China son las centrales térmicas de carbón.
No necesitan importarlo de otros países.
Y, como ya hemos visto en otros vídeos, eso
es todo un respiro.
Sin embargo, si hay una energía contaminante,
ese es el carbón.
Y por eso, China tiene un problema serio con
la contaminación.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Si no usamos carbón…
que otras alternativas nos quedan?
Una es la producción eléctrica con gas.
Actualmente China importa un 40% del gas que
consume.
Pero ya sabéis todos los problemas políticos
que tiene el gas.
Si recordáis, en este otro vídeo os contábamos
lo caro que es comprar gas en Asia.
Y eso explica noticias como esta.
El precio spot de GNL en Japón alcanza en
enero su máximo en 3 años
China compite con Japón por atraer a los
metaneros que circulan por el Pacífico, lo
que ha disparado los precios del GAS NATURAL
LIQUADO ya que Japón demanda mucho más gas
desde que paró sus nucleares tras Fukushima.
Por lo tanto, sólo queda una alternativa:
NUCLEAR.
Es eficiente, funciona todo el día y, por
extraño que parezca, es menos bastante menos
contaminante que otras alternativas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan sencillo!
Por un lado, las centrales nucleares necesitan
una tecnología cara de instalar y un combustible,
el uranio, que no te ponen en cualquier gasolinera.
Así que… ¿Cómo lo está haciendo China?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
MADE IN CHINA
Las falsificaciones chinas son legendarias.
Y sí, es lo que estáis pensando.
¿Qué hizo China para desarrollar su propia
industria nuclear?
Pues aprender de los mejores.
China trabajó en sus inicios mano a mano
con la francesa Framatome, la empresa estatal
conocida anteriormente como Areva.
También llegó a acuerdos con la americana
Westinghouse.
Incluso algunos reactores en China fueron
desarrollados por la compañía nuclear canadiense
o la rusa Rosatom.
¿Qué ocurrió a partir del año 2000?
Pues que China exigió a las compañías extranjeras
la transferencia de tecnología.
Por ejemplo, Westinghouse tuvo que permitir
que los ingenieros chinos pudieran aprender
todos sus secretos tecnológicos.
Sólo así podían adaptar los reactores a
las condiciones chinas.
Nadie negocia contratos como los Chinos.
Así que después de 10 años de trabajo,
la tercera generación de reactores nucleares
made in China ya está aquí:
China se prepara para arrancar el primer reactor
nuclear AP1000 del mundo
El acuerdo que firmaron entonces preveía
que ahora China construya sus propios reactores
sin participación de empresas extranjeras.
De esta forma, la tecnología de las decenas
de reactores que China va a construir en los
próximos años será 100% china.
Además, aunque Westinghouse quisiera expandir
su presencia en el mercado chino, parece que
lo tendrá muy difícil tras ver noticias
como esta:
Westinghouse podría verse afectada por las
nuevas restricciones de Estados Unidos sobre
las exportaciones nucleares
Pero si hay algo que no se puede copiar es
el uranio.
Las centrales nucleares utilizan el uranio
como combustible.
Y China carece de este mineral en su territorio.
Así que se han visto obligados a importarlo.
Pero los chinos también son hábiles comerciantes
y llevan años moviéndose bien.
Kazajistán produce el 40% del uranio del
mundo.
Pues bien, China ya importa el 50% de su producción.
También tiene acuerdos con Canadá y permanece
atenta a las grandes reservas de Australia.
Pero hay otros países con los que es más
sencillo llegar a acuerdos:
China compra a Rio Tinto una mina de uranio
de Namibia por 107 millones de dólares
China gana terreno en Níger para conseguir
el uranio que aumentará su producción nuclear
En definitiva, el made in China se ha extendido
a la industria nuclear mundial.
La joya de la Corona de sus proyectos, el
reactor Hualong One, ya se vende internacionalmente
y comenzará a operar durante la próxima
década en países como Argentina o Pakistán.
La empresa estatal china también participa
en la construcción de un nuevo reactor nuclear
en Reino Unido.
Pero eso es otra cuestión para otro vídeo.
Porque, como ya os podéis imaginar, este
es el primer capítulo de una nueva serie
de vídeos que iremos sacando en VisualPolitik.
Una serie donde os explicaremos todos los
detalles de la energía nuclear en el mundo.
Si no os lo queréis perder, ya sabéis: suscribíos
a VIsualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Mientras tanto, ahora la pregunta es ¿Hasta
dónde pensáis que llegarán los ambiciosos
planes energéticos del dragón chino?
¿Creéis que la nuclear seguirá creciendo
en China o terminarán cediendo su papel ante
el empuje de las energías renovables?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de Patreon, donde tendréis acceso
a contenido exclusivo.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!